Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Nicht wirklich morgen heute, ne?
Du sollst das immer nicht verraten. Die ich bin doch hier dreiundzwanzig Hacker. Ich habe doch Angst, dass jemand weiß, wann ich wo bin.
Ach so, du meinst äh die Illusion muss aufrecht erhalten werden.
Muss aufrecht halten, dass es früh am Morgen ist.
Ja, okay. Ja, ja. Ah, nächstes Mal nicht wieder so früh.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik äh wir schreiben das sechsundzwanzigste äh Episotion,
in unserer kleinen Infokolumne auf dem Internet und äh ja, heute haben wir auch mal wieder einen Gast dabei, nämlich Markus Kompa und den haben wir hier auch am Apparat. Hallo Markus.
Hallo. Hi.
Markus ist ähm Medienrechtsanwalt? Kann man, kann man Medienrechtsanwalt sagen oder muss man sagen, Rechtsanwalt für Medienrecht, weil der ist ja zweimal recht drin.
Ist es glaube ich nicht besonders geschützt. Kannst du sagen.
Okay, äh Mitglied der Piratenpartei, Zauberer und äh Blogger und Twitterer.
Auch das.
Multiple Identitäten und jetzt bist du auch noch Opfer geworden.
Und ohne Opfer.
Schon länger.
Genau, du bloggst seit einiger Zeit und äh wie lange bloggst du eigentlich schon?
Also mein Blog zum Medienrecht gibt's jetzt glaube ich drei, vier Jahre müsste ich mal gucken ich hab davor ein Watch Blog gemacht, ich hab also mich über die,
Finanzdienstleister mal sehr geärgert vor etwa sechs Jahren und,
gegen eine gewisse Firma bisschen geblockt, also die und die hat sich auch juristisch gewehrt. Das gab dann einen,
ersten Auftritt am Landgericht Hamburg in der berühmten Pressekammer. Ich habe mir fast drei Jahre einen kleinen Krieg gegen die deutsche Finanzindustrie geleistet,
Stunde der Parlamentäre und dann haben wir das begraben,
Ja und so bin ich halt zum Bloggen gekommen.
Und jetzt hast du mit deinem Blog aber auch Ärger bekommen. Das heißt, äh vielleicht lernen bald alle mit deinem Blog, weil du da einen Fall herbeigeführt hast. Ähm,
der dazu geeignet ist, ähm einige Wellen zu schlagen. Was was hast du denn gemacht.
Ja, also ich vertrete halt öfters Leute, die ähm eben Blogger, die ihre Meinungsfreiheit in einer Weise ausleben, die.
Manche sehr reich beläutete stört und manchmal vertrete ich Leute, die nur in Verdacht geraten, dass sie äh hinter irgendwelchen anonymen Blocks stecken und hier handelt es sich um das Blog ESO Watch,
äh war ein gewisser Herr Doktor Nikolaus Kler nicht drüber erfreut, der eben bei Iso Watch sehr
behandelt wird und insbesondere über Google wird der Mann sehr schnell gefunden. Doktor Klair ist ein Zeitgenosse, der seit über zwei Jahrzehnten wirklich
Medien verklagt, äh die nicht schnell genug auf dem Baum sind von der Lokalzeitung bis hin zum Fernsehsender
mit uns zusammen verklagte gerade ein kleines Familienunternehmen namens Google.
Google verantwortlich sei dafür, dass diese anonyme Seite von,
bei den ausgegeben würde und dass man dadrauf, äh ja, dass man eben,
diese Inhalte über Google findet. Der Doktor Claire hat äh bei YouTube sehr erfolgreich äh dafür gesorgt, dass man eben gewisse Mitschnitte von,
Magazine nicht findet, die über ihn berichtet haben, Panorama zum Beispiel hat die Band berichtet oder eben in dem Fall um den es bei uns geht ZDF wieso, der WISO-Detektiv hat sich dabei,
Doktor Claire eingeschlichen.
Der Doktor Claire denn.
Ja, was er macht. Also, er bietet seit zwei Jahrzehnten einige Therapien an,
mit denen ihr also Krebs heilen möchtet oder behandeln möchte. Das Problem ist nur, dass oder ich sage mal so, seine Klientel sind Leute, die im Endstadium sich befinden und sich an jeden Strohhalm klammern,
und diese Angebote, die der Herr Doktor Klär macht, äh
werden von der Fachwelt als, also deren Wirksamkeit ist von der Fachwelt neutral noch nicht festgestellt worden, auch wenn Herr Doktor eine andere Ansicht dazu hat, er schickt mir dicke Schriftsätze, äh warum seine Methode so schön sei
und behauptet jetzt auch, äh hat es auch drei Zeugen grade aufgefahren, die von ihm geheilt worden wären,
aber diese Zeugen sind irgendwie, naja gut, warten wir mal die, warten wir es mal ab, also es gab mal jemand, der im Umfeld von Doktor eine Wunderheilung erfuhr, das war der Schauspieler Ivan Disney.
Okay, also ähm.
Hodenkrebs gehabt und ist dann geheilt worden, bis sich dann herausstellt, er hatte nie Hodenkrebs.
Ist er noch besser?
Wurde die Story peinlich.
Ja ähm also Doktor wurde auch mal mit dem Galawied Skandal in Verbindung gebracht. Ist ein,
ein äh Medikament, das man in Russland bekommen kann für wenig Geld, das für was anderes verwendet wird
und hier in Deutschland wurde es als Krebsbehandlungsmittel eingesetzt
allerdings ähm das allerdings mit der exorbitanten Gewinnspanne, das Ganze wurde in einer Klinik gemacht äh der Herr kontrolliert hat,
aber davon nichts mitbekommen haben,
dafür musste dann ein Doktor Rauchfuß in den Knast, also es sind wirklich komische Geschichten. Im Moment wird Herrn Doktor gerade in Österreich der Prozess gemacht, äh ein Strafprozess und,
ähm ich berichte halt dadrüber.
Aber konkret getan hast, ist, du hast.
Ich hab auf einen YouTube Beitrag verlinkt der vom ZDF war der besagte Viso Detektiv.
Und äh das habe ich in der Weise gemacht, dass ich das in meinem Blog eingebunden habe,
Das spielt übrigens für das Landgericht Hamburg keine Rolle, ob man einen normalen Link setzt oder ob man eine Sache einbindet. Das war also auch äh eine neue Erkenntnis aus diesem Fall.
Ja und äh.
Du hast sozusagen über diesen normalen von YouTube angebotenen im Wedding Weg.
Genauer, genauer.
Rahmen deiner Berichterstattung. Da war dann ein ZDF-Bericht, in dem gesagt wurde, Doktor Claire, so und so nicht in Ordnung, was der macht.
Und der hatte sich dann, wenn ich das jetzt so richtig verstanden habe, hat der sich ja gegen das Z gegen das ZDF dann zur Wehr gesetzt und hatte.
Es ist mir zu Ohren gekommen,
Das war mir zu Ohren gekommen, deshalb habe ich überhaupt äh darüber berichtet, habe gesagt, guck mal hier. Das ist jetzt ein Ding, gegen das sich der Herr Doktor Klär gerade zur Wehr setzt, äh über den Herr Doktor Klär werde ich ihn,
noch mehr zu berichten haben. Und äh zu dem Zeitpunkt war mir nicht bekannt, äh ob es überhaupt schon Verbot gegeben hat, äh sondern nur, dass sie
Doktor Klär, irgendwas störte und der Witz ist, dass der Doktor Claire eben gegen viele Dinge vorgeht, die einfach nicht falsch sind, ja?
Zum Beispiel die Behauptung, äh Herr Professor Hege, hätte Herrn Doktor ein erwerbsgetriebenes Ungeheuer genannt, das hat er getan, das können sie in den Panoramabeitrag sehen, das ist auch nicht ernsthaft streitig. Trotzdem behauptet er, er hätte das nicht getan,
dann muss erstmal derjenige, der in Anspruch genommen wird, beweisen, dass es, dass er das doch getan hat,
Wir haben nämlich im Äußerungsrecht die Beweislastumkehr, das heißt äh der Kläger kann sich einfach hinsetzen und sagen, nö, hat er nicht, macht mal. Und wenn man dann nicht innerhalb äh kürzester Zeit oder,
je nachdem welche Verfahrensart jetzt gewählt wird. Wenn man es also nicht schafft, das zu beweisen, dann verliert man.
Und im einstweiligen Verfügungsverfahren ist es sogar noch witziger, da wird man gar nicht erst angehört,
Falls im Regelfall, wenn's am Landgericht Hamburg stattfindet. Aber ich verfrans mich jetzt in Details.
Gut, also der dieser Herr hat also eine einstweilige Verfügung über das Landgericht Hamburg erwirkt? Gegen dich.
Ja. Gegen mich äh.
Weil du dieses YouTube-Video eingebunden hattest in deinem Blog.
Weil in diesem Video drei Punkte medienrechtlich beanstandet wurden, die auch dem ZDF dann eine einstweilige Verfügung,
äh eingebracht haben, die auch erstinstanzlich bestätigt wurde
Eine Sache ist, es wurde mit einer versteckten Kamera in einer Arztpraxis gedreht und zwar im äh im Thekenbereich. Die Leute waren verpixelt, es gab da überhaupt nichts zu sehen. Das war
lediglich zu Illustrationen, weder Doktor Klär war da noch, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, irgendein Patient, jedenfalls es wurde niemand identifiziert, ernsthaft. Äh trotzdem,
ist eben das Landgericht Hamburg plötzlich der Meinung, dass das eine dass das eben,
Eingriff entweder ins Persönlichkeitsrecht ist oder eben in den Paragraph zweihunderteins A StGB, nämlich einen Raum, der gegen ein sich besonders geschützt ist, damit wollte man das verhindern, dass man
in einer Sauna macht, äh da gehören halt keine Kameras hin,
und eine Arztpraxis kann ein solcher Raum sein, allerdings noch herrschener Main nur dann, wenn das auch so,
benutzt wurde, wenn es also ein Behandlungszimmer ist, da gehört auch keine Fernsehkamera rein, wobei es auch durchaus Urteile gibt, die versteckte Kamera in solchen Fällen zugelassen haben, Wallraff Urteil, wenn nämlich einer besondere,
ein besonderes Berichtsinteresse besteht.
Okay und das war ja, mit dem da jetzt nicht unbedingt der Fall, wenn man da ohnehin nix gesehen hat, dann.
Richtig. Äh diese Argumentation, die hat natürlich nicht funktioniert, deshalb haben wir das da auch nicht vertieft. Aber äh der Eingangsbereich eines ähm,
eine Arztpraxis ist nun wirklich nichts, was irgendwie,
das ist keine besondere Intimität und nichts, also wir hätten die Tür filmen können, ja, das wäre zulässig gewesen, wer da reingeht.
Mhm. Okay, aber du hast jetzt ähm letztendlich, um mal auf deinen Fall den aktuellen zurückzukommen, da geht es ja, glaube ich, nicht mehr genau darum, sondern es geht darum, dass du das Ding eingebunden hast.
Nein, nein, äh das ist das ist zwar die äh ich meine, wenn man mir das verbietet, muss ich natürlich das Ding komplett rausnehmen,
es geht darum, hafte ich für das, äh was, was in diesem Film zu sehen ist. Das Landgericht Hamburg stellt sich
auf den Standpunkt, dass ich genauso haften muss wie der Intendant des zweiten Deutschen Fernsehens, also der haftet jetzt nicht persönlich, sondern das ZDF haftet. ZDF hat eine riesige Rechtsabteilung. Das ZDF hat auch Geld, die können sich auch ein sehr
Anwalt leisten. Ähm und das wird jetzt mir als Blogger zugemutet. Die Blogger, die was schreiben, die haften genauso wie Zeitung.
Ja und ich hafte die jetzt als Fernsehanstalt, ja, das ist absurd.
Das heißt, dadurch, dass du das eingebunden hast.
Gehen Sie davon aus, dass du dir das irgendwie quasi zu eigen machst oder also als was interpretiert denn dieses Landgericht jetzt deinen Akt des Einbindens eines ZDF-Beitrags? Was ist das denn jetzt? Machst du dir den zu eigen? Ähm das ist deiner, also warum haftest du da?
Ich mache es zugänglich. Ich müsste jetzt, ich habe das Urteil jetzt erstmal äh beiseite gelegt, weil ich mich also,
euch auch emotional ein bisschen sauer drüber war und weil ich ganz einfach gesagt habe, das mit der Haftung äh Thomas Stadler, das machst du. Thomas Starkler ist sicherlich den meisten Hörern bekannt, ein exzellenter Fachanwalt für eben diese für IT-Recht,
der vor allen Dingen auch schon von Anfang an dabei ist, der hat den der war noch zu Zeiten dabei als dieser Verein gegründet wurde,
Und dann äh rede ich da auch gar nicht rein, das muss er machen. Und das macht er auch gut.
Okay und Thomas Stadler ist derjenige, den du jetzt beauftragt hast.
Der hatte also mich also erst in zwanzig vertreten, ist also extra aus München nach Hamburg gereist und hat dort seine erste Erfahrung mit der Hamburger Pressekammer gemacht und ähm äh das Wort, das er benutzte, hinterher war ernüchternd.
Was ist denn mit dieser mit diesem Landgericht und dieser Pressekamera? Weil das das hört man jetzt äh bei der Schilderung dieses Falles die ganze Zeit. Ähm du lässt es anklingen, dass da irgendwas anders sei als äh sonst.
Ja, also zunächst wir haben den sogenannten fliegenden Gerichtsstand im Presserecht, das heißt, überall, wo eine Zeitung erscheint oder,
Fernsehsender gesehen werden kann oder wo man Internet abruft, äh,
Überall dort ist Gerichtsort, Tatort und äh im Presserecht kann man also überall dort eine Klage anhängig machen. Und dass irgendeinem geheimnisvollen Grund werden
'ne Menge solcher Klagen in Hamburg anhänglich gemacht, die Hamburger sind dafür bekannt, dass sie eben in
im gewerblichen Rechtsschutz in in urheberrechtlichen Angelegenheiten und eben vor allem im Medien- und Presserecht die schärfsten Urteile sprechen. Sie haben also ganz seltsame Auffassung, äh einmal bei der Beurteilung von von Sachverhalten
und dann bei der juristischen Bewertung, also Hamburg verbietet grundsätzlich immer, wenn man das nur irgendwie hinkriegen kann. Ich habe letztes Mal ein letztes Jahr habe ich mal ein Experiment gemacht, ich habe also selber mal
ein Verbot durchsetzen wollen gegen jemand der es wirklich verdient hat und der selber auch viel in Hamburg ausgeteilt hat und das hab ich in,
München anhängig gemacht und Köln und dann in Berlin und dann in Hamburg.
München und äh Köln haben also gesagt, äh hier die Person, um die es geht, ist gar nicht erkennbar und wenn sie's wäre, dann wäre das wohl von der Meinungsfreiheit geschützt,
Verbot kriegst du nicht
Berlin hat noch ein bisschen rumgeeiert und sah die Probleme auch und aus Hamburg ist einfach nur ein Briefumschlag gekommen, da war die einstweilige Verfügung drin mit anderen Worten, sie kriegen nirgendwo so billig eine einstweilige Verfügung wie in Hamburg. Warum die so sind, weiß ich nicht.
Wie heißt das im Moment heißt das, ich kann mir den ganzen Tag überlegen äh und ein Gericht nach dem anderen durchprobieren, wenn du sagst, du konntest erst Berlin, München und dann irgendwann Hamburg?
Bei einer konventionellen Klage kann man das nicht im einstweiligen Verfügungsverfahren kann man sogar gleichzeitig äh äh an mehreren Gerichten die Verfügung anhängig machen und gucken, wo es klappt. Also im Medienrecht gibt's so einige Prozesstricks und.
Mhm. Okay und irgendwann hat sich rumgesprochen, irgendwie in Hamburg habe ich äh gute Karten, die bei denen sitzt der Koll locker.
Ja, also Hamburg hat äh eben eine lange Tradition, hat der Wallraff hat ja auch äh dort seine Erfahrung gemacht
und kann ihn da auch erstaunliche Sachen berichten. Interessant in Hamburg ist der damalige, da gab's einen bekannten Richter, der auch am OLG mal gewesen ist und der hat dann direkt oder sehr kurz nach seinem Ausscheiden aus dem aktiven Richterdienst
hat er mit dem damals bekanntesten Presserechtler eine Kanzlei zusammen gegründet,
Ist auch heute noch der bekannteste Presserichter und das heißt also der der ehemalige Richter hat also die Fronten gewechselt,
ist gegenüber seinen Kollegen aufgetreten, die er selber eingenordet hatte. Und ähm einer davon ist halt der,
Richter Herr Buske, mit dem ich so eine äh Passliebe habe, der eben lange die Pressekammer geleitet hat und jetzt am Oberlandesgericht sitzt,
und da die entsprechenden Senat macht, der wird also künftig die Urteile überprüfen. Äh.
Siehst du da jetzt ein also siehst du da jetzt einfach nur handwerkliche Mängel oder gibt es da irgendwie eine generelle Tendenz in die diese Gericht immer abschweift, ist es das.
Letzteres. Die die Leute sind gut, sie haben auch sowas wie eine innere Logik. Das Problem ist, dass diese Logik von den Richtern in Karlsruhe am Bundesgerichtshof und in am Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht geteilt wird. Also,
praktisch alle bekannteren Urteil, die ihren Weg aus der Pressekammer Richtung Karlsruhe gefunden haben, wurden aufgehoben.
Also ich habe da mal einen Beitrag gemacht auf Telepolist, da heißt Hamburg hört in Karlsruhe auf und äh
sind so einige Fälle eben ähm aufgeführt. Es gibt in Hamburg wirklich die absurdesten Urteile. Äh da können sie sich nachlesen, ich kann jetzt schlicht alle aufzeichnen, sonst sitzen wir heute Abend noch da,
ähm aber äh ja zum Beispiel ist, dass der Kanzler sich die die Haare äh nee, ich dachte,
Ich sprech's besser nicht aus, sonst kriegt ihr auch noch eine einstweilige Verfügung. Lasst mir jetzt.
Jetzt ähm.
Vielleicht sind wir hier schon viel zu weit gegangen.
Kommt noch ein ein Punkt, jetzt kommen wir nämlich mal ganz langsam zu deiner äh Aktion der Kläranlage.
Du hast jetzt gesagt, okay, Erstinstanzlich hast du da unterlegen in dieser Angelegenheit,
Das Thema ist aber relativ wichtig, weil es äh also wenn wir demnächst alle für YouTube Videoeinbindungen haften, dann haben wir ähm nicht nur ein Problem, dass es an die ganze Zeit irgendwelche ähm,
einstweiligen Verfügung regnet, sondern vor allem auch, dass wir irgendwie in Form der Selbstzensur springen, ja? Und was ja auch relativ wichtig von dir herausgestellt wurde, war,
dass du ja gar nicht wissen konntest, wie der Stand jetzt irgendwie beim ZDF ist, also ähm
ob was denen da jetzt irgendwie verboten wird oder nicht und vor allem kommt ja dann noch hinzu, dass Links, die man einmal in seinem Blog erstellt, ja, also die Tendenz haben da zu bleiben.
Irgendwie fünf Jahre später, wenn irgendwelche Verfahren dann ergeben haben, dass das jetzt nicht in Ordnung war, sagen kann, okay, jetzt muss ich dieses Video irgendwie entfernen oder was auch immer. Ähm,
Aus diesem Grund hast du gesagt, okay, dieses Thema ist zu wichtig. Das muss jetzt irgendwie mal äh äh ausgefochten werden.
Wir hatten gehofft, dass wir in in der ersten Instanz durchaus äh mit der Sache durchdringen, ganz einfach, weil diese diese Haftungsargumentation vom
Landgericht Hamburg nicht überzeugt, es gibt da dieses Urteil, dass man eben auf Links verlinken darf, Kommunikationsfreiheit und so weiter.
Da ging's, glaube ich, um eine Computerzeitschrift. War das Chip oder PC-Welt? CT.
Also.
Doch heiser, okay, ich muss ich dachte, es wäre nicht heiß gewesen. Die irgendwie auf auf dieses Programm verlinkt haben, was die ermöglicht hat, was ermöglicht hat, Kopierschütze zum gehen von DVDs, was damals noch oder heute auch noch, glaube ich.
Genau. Es war lange umstritten, aber letzten Endes wurde da auch pro heise äh geurteilt.
Auch erst vor einem halben Jahr oder so oder vor einem Jahr oder wann?
Länger, aber äh so ungefähr, ja.
Und äh auf dieses Urteil haben wir uns berufen, dass äh Landgericht Hamburg meinte, wir hätten das falsch verstanden, ähm ich glaube nicht, dass der Staatler das falsch verstanden hat. Ähm und das Problem ist jetzt, wenn ich dieses Urteil jetzt,
rechtskräftig hätte werden lassen, dann würde dieses Urteil von etlichen Anwälten genommen werden, um wie man im Jargon sagt,
Honig daraus zu saugen. Mir ist schon mal sowas passiert vor drei, vier Jahren. Da ging es darum, dass ein Mandant von mir äh,
angeblich für angeblich werden ihm E-Mails zugesandt worden und da hat diese E-Mails veröffentlicht und dann ging's darum
dass er wie er davon überhaupt zugesandte E-Mails veröffentlichen, insbesondere dann, wenn man
das vorher androht, dass man's tut oder ist das ein Eingriff ins Persönlichkeitsrecht. Das Landgericht Köln hatte damals ein Fehlurteil gemacht, das ich leider nicht abwenden konnte
und äh diese Entscheidung ist halt von vielen,
Gerichten äh und auch von vielen Anwälten und leider auch von vielen Gerichten aufgegriffen worden, obwohl die nie rechtskräftig wurde. Die Parteien haben sich in diesem Falle verglichen
und das äh habe ich versucht, bekannt zu machen, aber es ist nicht bekannt genug geworden. Das heißt, diese Entscheidung wird immer wieder aufs Brot geschmiert und wir brauchen halt eine Möglichkeit,
um zu verhindern, dass diese Entscheidung missbraucht werden kann. Wir brauchen jetzt eine obergerechtliche Entscheidung und die wird wahrscheinlich nur aus Karlsruhe zu erwarten sein.
Was ist denn jetzt der nächste juristische Schritt? Bleibt es jetzt erstmal bei dem selben Gericht und geht da in Revision oder gibt es dann automatisch zu einem anderen?
In Berufung zum Oberlandesgericht. Der Senat wird von meinem Lieblingsrichter geleitet, der allerdings an diesem Urteil nicht mehr mitwirken wird, weil,
in der Utainistanz in Verfügungsverfahren befasst war, aber natürlich äh sind die Leute eingemordet. Das heißt, wir
erwarten also vom Oberlandesgericht Hamburg nicht so viel. Interessant ist, dass die im letzten Jahr eigentlich sehr viel von der Pressekammer aufgehoben haben, aber wenn jetzt der Vorsitzende der Pressekammer da den Vorsitz macht und äh da sind wir nicht sehr optimistisch. Das heißt, äh
wir haben also im, am Oberlandesgericht gerade mal noch die Möglichkeit, Fehler zu machen, aber wir können da keinen Blumentopf gewinnen. Danach geht es also weiter äh zum,
zum sechsten Senat in des Bundesgerichtshofs, der eben durchaus weiß, dass die Bahnhofsfreiheit einen Wert hat und äh,
erhoffen wir uns einen Sieg, wobei vor Gericht und auch hoher See ist meine Gotteshand.
Ja. Also letzten Endes würdest du das bis wohin treiben wollen.
Äh zum für Menschenrechte von mir aus. Keine Ahnung. Also es das Problem ist halt äh an dem Fall kann ich nur die Freiheit gewinnen künftig dieses Video,
zu verlinken oder wie auch immer. Ja, also Geld kann ich damit nicht verdienen. Ich kann damit nur Geld verlieren. Und das sind in dem Fall zwanzigtausend Euro und der Größenordnung,
möglicherweise noch Zeugen geladen und das das kann also beliebig teuer werden. Und ich habe in die Sache schon einige tausend gesteckt und äh zwanzigtausend habe ich halt einfach nicht rumliegen.
Ich war halt also das Uta kam kam vor einer Woche und wir haben uns überlegt, was machen wir? Ähm
Paar Leute, die davon gehört haben, haben sogar Angebote gemacht, aber äh ich ich kann nicht andere Leute Geld verzocken, also,
das hat mir überhaupt nicht behakt und äh dann haben mich mehrere Leute drauf angesprochen, haben gesagt, Crowdfunding, wie auch immer,
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ähm na gut, also wenn,
die ganzen Leute, die meinen Blog umsonst lesen, die mir auf Twitter folgen, die gut finden, was ich mache, wenn von denen einfach jeder sagt,
zwanzig Euro tun mir nicht weh,
Euro investiere ich da, äh dann müsste es zumindest möglich sein, ein Teil dieses Verfahrens damit zu finanzieren,
und habe das heute gestern einfach mal geblockt und äh,
das hat dann über Twitter und äh andere Medien ähm die Runde gemacht.
Also viel, viel muss ich natürlich erwähnen, der da den ich jetzt ja seit einigen Jahren auch kenne, der auch an auch dieses Verfahren so ein bisschen beobachtet hat und äh das ist gestern plötzlich,
rumgegangen in einer Weise, die ich jetzt so nicht erwartet hätte. Und ähm als ich dann vierundzwanzig Stunden später heute Morgen äh mein Konto mir angesehen habe, da,
Tränen in den Augen gehabt. Da ist tatsächlich äh also schon die Hälfte zusammengekommen.
Tendenz steigen und viele Leute ähm haben ja erst gestern angewiesen und es ist noch nicht gebucht, also da ich ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sagen soll. Ich habe vor Jahren immer schon äh so einen Verein für sinnvoll gehalten, also einen Verein, der ähm,
der einen Fonds auf verwaltet oder eine Stiftung oder irgendwas, die eben für Anliegen, die seriös sind,
'ne Prozessfinanzierung anbietet, also ich habe etliche Blogger vertreten, die meistens eben Hartz vierer waren,
oder der Begriff ist eigentlich, eigentlich sollte man den Begriff gar nicht verwenden. Also jedenfalls, Blogger, die nicht, die keinen Pfennig auf der Naht hatten oder keinen Cent,
die von meist sehr ekelhaften Leuten äh in der Regel auch nach Hamburg gebieten wurden und äh,
ja, es, es hat mir halt weh getan, dass es dass ich denen nicht wirklich was anbieten konnte, die meisten Sachen musste man halt einfach dann ab irgendeinem Stadium sagen, Leute, ihr könnt die äh den Rechtsweg nicht bezahlen. Also ich,
ja ich ich rede jetzt nicht von meinem Honorar, ja ähm sondern der Rechtsweg.
Kosten, ne? Das heißt, die Situation ist jetzt ähm erstmal so, dass du da voll auf Angriff äh schalten kannst und wirst.
Ja, es ist der, es ist einer der, also der erste Prozess in eigener Sache, wo ich äh eben
jetzt plötzlich sagen kann, ich kann heute Abend etwas ruhiger schlafen. Äh damals, als ich mich mit der Finanzindustrie eingelegt habe, da ist es schon an die Reserven gegangen und es waren alle, also das waren sehr riskante Sache, aber
ich bin halt irgendwo auch manchmal ein Dickkopf oder Rebell oder wie soll man's sagen. Damals hat sich's gelohnt am Schluss.
Jetzt gucken wir mal also äh.
Was bei rauskommt.
Ja, ich bin, ich bin sehr, sehr gerührt, sehr ähm also die Solidarität hätte ich jetzt so nicht erwartet, dass das in dem Maße funktioniert. Äh gut, es ist natürlich auch Herr Doktor Klär jemand, der äh.
Oh, jetzt musst du vorsicht, jetzt musst du vorsichtig sein, nicht dass äh.
Stimuliert, dass man ihn nicht sympathisch findet.
Ähm du hast nur noch mal, um das abzuschließen, wenn du das nämlich jetzt wirklich durch alle Instanzen treiben musst und dann letzte Instanz nicht gewinnst, dann muss die Gegenseite dieses Geld bezahlen.
Macht er aus der Portokasse.
Und okay, das ist in Ordnung und für den Fall würdest du nämlich dieses Geld zurückbekommen und hast gesagt, dann möchtest du genau diesen, diese Idee des Vereins eines irgendwie für
so eine so eines Meinungsfreiheits-Fonds dann mit diesem Geld realisieren. Da hast du aber noch nicht äh detailliert jetzt äh
gesprochen, denn sowas zieht sich ja eh wahrscheinlich über Jahre hin.
Das muss man erstmal gucken, auch dass das steuerrechtlich irgendwie für die also da gibt's so ein paar Details zu zu prüfen, in welcher Rechtsform man das macht. Ich habe damit keine Erfahrung
Und ähm also ich esse mal die Leute, die mir äh das jetzt praktisch für diese Sache zweckgebunden gegeben haben, die haben natürlich den Anspruch, das zurückzukriegen. Viele Leute haben im im der Überweisungsbetreffzeile angegeben, dass sie das gar nicht zurückhaben wollen, dass das für einen
Verein äh benutzt werden soll. Und ähm ja, also,
Den Fall, wir kriegen es zurück und das ist ein Überschuss, dann wird halt hinterher Kassensturz gemacht und äh geguckt, wer von diesen zwanzig Zwanzigern äh was zurückhaben will,
machen wir so ein Verein, das ist absolut überfällig gewesen. Wobei, ich sage jetzt immer die zwanziger, es waren also einige Geldbeträge, die,
erheblich höher waren und.
Ja, ich denke, hier zeichnet sich halt natürlich auch ab, dass das hier wirklich ein Thema ist, was potenziell alle, die im Netz halbwegs äh publizieren unterwegs sind, äh ganz äh unmittelbar betreffen kann.
Und das schon morgen schon, ne? Gut Markus,
Ähm dann sage ich mal erstmal viel äh Glück hier auf der äh weiteren äh Reise mit dieser ganzen Angelegenheit, sowas an der Backe zu haben, ist äh auch so keine Freude, selbst wenn's jetzt keine finanziellen Sorgen gibt, ne? Insofern.
Erstmals ja.
Wünschen wir dir erst mal eine glückliche Hand.
Ich möchte mich bei allen bedanken, die sehr gerührt.
Markus, viel Erfolg weiterhin und bis dahin.
Danke, tschüss.
So, was äh haben wir denn sonst noch auf der Uhr?
Wir haben noch den Julian Assange auf der Uhr,
Hat heute auch ein Gerichtsverfahren und zwar vor dem Supreme Court in England, Großbritannien.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete.
Netzkritik berichtete, in aller Vielfalt. Und ähm es ging also um seine Weigerung gegen die.
Auslieferung.
Gegen die Auslieferung an Schweden und die Frage war quasi, sind Staatsanwälte juristische Instanzen?
Das müssen in Großbritannien muss es quasi ein Richter sein, der in äh äh so einen Auslieferungsantrag stellt.
Oder diesen Haftbefehl ausgestellt hat, ähm damit das als juristische Instanz respektiert ist. Und,
in Schweden, die jetzt da das Assance habhaft werden wollen, ähm war das ja die Staatsanwältin. Mit dieser, mit dieser Frage sind die tatsächlich vor diesen äh obersten Gerichtshof gezogen.
Und es gab im Prinzip zwei Möglichkeiten. Ähm das obere Gericht sagt, nee, das sind keine juristischen Instanzen. Dieser,
und Auslieferungsantrag ist äh nicht gültig, dann wäre die Reaktion von Schweden gewesen. Alles klar, dann stellt jetzt ein Richter ein,
Ja, also da gab's eigentlich nicht viel zu gewinnen. Oder Assange verliert.
Und ähm da wurde halt gesagt, dann ruft er halt irgendwie den äh Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte in Straßburg an. Ja, äh um sich dann gegen diese gegen diese Sache zu wehren. Das waren so die die Prognosen für diesen Fall. Also eigentlich ein ein äh,
Also, dass ihm das nicht peinlich ist mit so einem Quatsch da irgendwie, äh die, die, die Leute zu belästigen. Na ja, okay. Ähm das Problem war, ähm,
Worauf dann in der schwedischen Presse äh aufmerksam gemacht wurde,
das wurde dann auf dem Twitter-Account natürlich als als Schmierschmierkampagne oder was interpretiert. Das Problem war, das hätte auch Implikationen für einen Mordfall. Da gab's jetzt irgendwie einen,
geständiges Brüderpaar, was in irgendeinem Mord verwickelt war und einer sitzt da jetzt grade im anderen Land.
Und da soll auch eine Auslieferung angestrengt werden.
Und wie Markus das ja gerade auch schon sagte, wenn jetzt so ein hohes Gericht irgendwie ein Urteil spricht und sagt, äh was weiß ich, ne, in in England werden keine äh,
Auslieferung, es wird kein Auslieferungsbescheiden, Auslieferungsanträgen Folge geleistet die von irgendwelchen Staatsanwälten kommen,
Dann ähm hätten sich auch alle anderen Gerichte daran halten müssen oder wären nach diesem Urteil gegangen und dann hätte das eben eine Implikation gehabt, dass nämlich auch ein Auslieferungsantrag für einen bestimmten Mörder.
Fallen gelassen werden hätte.
Gelassen hätte.
Ja, getan, getäten.
Aber um mal auch zu zeigen, dass ned also wie gesagt, die Wiki Leaks Interpretation war, dass das quasi eine ein Versuch ist, Assange in schlechtes Licht zu rücken,
Ähm aber wie Markus ja gerade auch schon so sagte, solche Urteile haben auch Folgen, ja, es geht nicht nur um den einen Fall, ja? Und wenn er schon mit so einem mit so einer Frage, Staatsanwalt oder Richter, da vor den, vor den obersten Gerichtshof zieht,
kann man sich eben auch ausmalen, dass das für andere Leute noch Folgen hat. So, mehr weiß ich da jetzt gar nicht zu zu beurteilen. Ähm ob das jetzt äh also auf jeden Fall diese Schmiere, Hinweis, äh der ist da an der Stelle wahrscheinlich nicht so unbedingt
angemessen. Na ja, wie entscheidet dieser Supreme Court, dass äh der oberste Richtshof Großbritanniens ähm,
entscheidet genau wie die anderen äh Gerichte, die mit dem Fall vorher angestrengt worden waren, zwei Stück waren's ja schon und sagt, ja, ist schon in Ordnung so.
Und ähm berufst sich aber in der Urteilsbegründung auf die Wiener Konvention für die Menschenrechte. Und ähm,
Also sie wusste nicht, ich wir war jetzt nicht unbedingt bekannt, was das ist und wenn man das so googelt, findet man auch nur irgendwelche kryptischen Wikipedia Artikel. Ungefähr so haben wohl dann auch die Anwälte von Assange reagiert.
Und ähm haben dann gesagt, so hä, davon haben wir ja noch nie gehört oder oder davon war eben im, in diesem gesamten Verfahren nie die Rede. Ähm und deswegen haben sie sogar jetzt eine vierzehntägige Berufungsfrist eingeräumt bekommen von diesem Gericht selbst,
Das heißt, die können sich jetzt überlegen, ob sie nochmal Berufung vor dem gleichen Gericht haben wollen, äh dann könnte das Gericht diese Berufung zulassen oder ablehnen.
Und ähm ja sagen wir mal, sie lassen's zu, dann verhandeln sie es nochmal, entscheiden sie sich wahrscheinlich nicht anders. Ähm,
oder sie lehnen sie halt ab und dann könnte Asance halt hier für den vor den Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte in Straßburg gehen, aber ich denke mal, irgendwann muss ihm das auch äh selber wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu blöd werden, was,
Was da irgendwie los ist, ja? Ähm.
Also das.
Er will da wirklich nicht hin, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Er will da wirklich nicht hin und langsam fragt man sich wieso. Ja, also muss da jetzt wirklich mal folge ja immer noch Wiki Leaks auf Twitter, da kriege ich mindestens, ach was weiß ich,
täglich, aber ich lese es nur jeden zweiten Tag irgendwie
die Meldung, wie viele Tage, Assange, irgendwie fünfhundertvierzig Tage oder oder was, da ist ein Zeh. Da kriege ich jeden Tag ins Auge gedrückt. Ähm
Ja, wenn einer sich durch drei ins durch alle Instanzen kämpft, mit irgendwelchen Formfehlern, weil er auf Teufel komm raus, nicht nach Schweden möchte.
Ja, so läuft das nun mal, ne. Ich meine, wenn wenn ein Auslieferungsbescheid eben wenn der eine Auslieferung beschlossen ist und du kämpfst dagegen an, ist ja klar, dass du in der Zeit nicht irgendwie rumrennen kannst. Ist ja ganz klar. Man muss ja davon ausgehen, dass der Fluchtgefahr besteht.
Na ja, also ähm ins zunehmende Maße wirklich einfach nur noch ärgerlich, was was da stattfindet. Ja, also
kein faires Verfall. Ihnen erwartet kein faires Verfahren in Schweden. Er wird jetzt gesagt, dann früher hieß es ja die Schweden äh schießen ihn raus nach an die USA und dann wird er da umgebracht oder so. Ähm.
Ja, also weiß ich nicht mehr. Inzwischen geht mir das nur noch auf den Geist. Vielleicht hat er ja Informationen, die ich nicht habe, aber ähm.
In dieser Angelegenheit wäre es ganz schön, wenn man da jetzt mal langsam vorwärts kommen würde. Und diesen diesen Vorwurf da auf sich sitzen zu lassen ähm über zwei Jahre, da tut er sich auch keinen Gefallen mit. Also ich weiß nicht, wer ihn da,
ihn da berät, PR-technisch, ja. Ähm,
du hattest ja auch schon in einer anderen Folge schon gesagt, so das würden die Schweden sich aber auch nicht gefallen lassen, dass ihre Regierung oder ihre Justiz den Assange sich erst mit,
Wegen ähm sexuellen Übergriffen fischt und dann wegen der Wiki Leakstätigkeit an die USA ausliefert. Ähm da hätten wir noch einen kleinen Gewaltausbruch in Schweden wahrscheinlich.
Also man weiß nicht, was was ihnen da jetzt reitet und ich finde, das wird auch immer sektiererischer um Wiki Leaks. Ja, also was, was, was, was da jetzt irgendwie mit diesem und faul, dieses dieses Social Network, da sind die auch den ganzen Tag mit am twittern, ne und
der Assange der Held und jeder, der irgendwas zu Assange sagt, wird, wird dann dem tausendfach auf Twitter zitiert und und wie viele Tage der schon da im Knast ist, also
Wiki Leaks Theater, ja. So, das war der, der, der, der Wikirand hier.
Weil's so schön ist, bleiben wir gleich in den Gerichtssälen. Das scheint ja hier das äh alles bestimmte Thema zu sein. Ähm ja.
Dresden, wir hatten es besprochen, ich denke auch in mehreren Folgen.
Die Funkzellenabfrage in Dresden anlässlich des Naziaufmarsches, der dort stattgefunden hat, wurden,
eigentlich die gesamte Dresdner Innenstadt wurden die Funkzellen abgefragt. Ähm Andre war ja bei uns auch schon zu Besuch und hat das nochmal genauer erklärt, was eine Funktion Abfrage ist und dass das ja auch in Berlin stattgefunden hat im Rahmen der Autobrände
Ähm und jetzt durfte offensichtlich dieses Amtsgericht Dresden äh sich der Frage nähern,
in der Frage urteilen, ob diese Funkzellenabfrage, die da stattgefunden hat und von diesem selbigen Gericht eigentlich,
Äh damals angeordnet wurde.
Ob das denn so rechtens war? Also sie konnte das Amtgericht Dresden sollte jetzt entscheiden, ob seine eigene Entscheidung legal war und es gab völlig überraschend raus, ja.
Egal, was wir da gemacht haben.
Ein glücklicher Zufall auch. Ja. Ja.
Schwein gehabt, so. Und dann gab's äh,
Dann gab's also eine kurze PDF ein kurze PDF-Zeit. Eine kurze PDF, eine kurze PM, Pressemitteilung äh vom,
Vom Pressesprecher der Staatsanwaltschaft Dresden, der sagte, ja Amtsgericht Dresden erklärt Funktionabfrage zum neunzehnten Februar zweitausendelf rechtsmäßig, rechtmäßig mein Landgericht Landesgericht Landesgericht Amt,
Gericht.
Ja äh heute äh passen die Worte nicht mehr so richtig zusammen. Ich bin kurz davor, erst die Handel zu zitieren.
Oje, da lass mal. Äh vielleicht kommt's noch. Also für linksmäßig. Ringsmäßig.
Das Amtsgericht Dresden hat dann eben gesagt, OK das war alles in Ordnung und zwar weil das irgendwie um groß großzügige, groß, große Straftaten ging,
Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wer dann da jetzt im Rahmen dieser dieser Gegendemonstration zum Naziaufmarsch da irgendwie gerade eine kriminelle Vereinigung gebildet hat äh und na ja, also,
dieses Thema, ich denke, haben wir schon relativ ausführlich behandelt. Ähm.
Posse geht weiter.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt weitergeht. Ich bin mal gespannt, wer sich da jetzt, wie man sich jetzt dagegen wehren kann oder nicht. Also äh,
Ist leider mir nicht so ganz klar, äh wie man sich jetzt irgendwie dagegen,
wehren kann, aber also mir ist sowieso unklar, dass ein Amtsgericht irgendwie am einen Tag vor so einer Demo so ein Ding äh so ein so ein Beschluss erlässt und dann irgendwie äh,
Ein Jahr später, nee, beziehungsweise nicht vor der Demo ein paar ein paar Tage nach der Demo so einen Beschluss erlässt und irgendwie anderthalb Jahre später dann beurteilt, übrigens, weil legal, was wir da gemacht haben. Also, irgendwie ein bisschen unklar, weil in Dresden ist das sowieso alles ein bisschen unklar
dem der interessierte Hörer sei da auf ein paar Artikel verwiesen, die ich da noch verlinkt habe.
Ja, ansonsten zur Verteidigung des Internets gibt's ja auch noch andere Maßnahmen.
Genau die Internetdefense League hat sich gegründet ähm.
Die haben so also in ihrer in ihrem Gründungsgründungsmythos äh sagen sie, ja ähm wir hatten ja, dass diese mit unserem Blackout haben wir ja Sopa und Piper den,
stop online und den Protect International ich hab's geschafft.
Bekämpft, erfolgreich und jetzt wollen wir sicherstellen, dass das Internet nie verliert, niemals. Und ähm dann haben sie relativ namhafte Gruppen und Einzelpersonen irgendwie mit zu ihrem.
Gründungsmitgliedern gemacht, also die IFF Wordpress, Redit, äh dieses Cheeseburger, Network und so weiter.
Genau und dies, dies, es scheint erstmal so zu sein, dass sie ähm.
Versuchen wollen, irgendwie so eine Art ähm so eine Art,
irgendwie Leute dazu bringen, quasi ihre Seiten so 'ne,
so eine Art in Anführungszeichen Bot Netz anzuschließen, was die Internet-Defense liegt, dann ausschalten kann. Also du kriegst quasi so einen Code,
Snippet, was du bei dir in die Seite einbaust, was irgendwie auf deren Zutun dann bestimmte Dinge darstellen kann oder nicht.
Sodass du äh dass man irgendwie denen die Möglichkeit geben würde.
Wenn das Internet in Gefahr ist, kann dann die Internetdefense League remote deine Seite irgendwie ähm abschalten oder ähm.
Schwarz machen.
Oder schwarz machen oder so.
Trauen Sie uns, wir machen es nur, wenn es wirklich nötig ist.
Ja, sie sagen, sie sagen dir vorher Bescheid, also eigentlich finde ich das gar keine so blöde Idee. Es gab das ja auch zum Beispiel der ähm AK Vorrat hat ja auch diese diese Ecke, die irgendwie an den an den Webseiten oben rechts runterhing und konnten das auch neu bespielen,
wir haben im Rahmen von digitaler Gesellschaft so 'ne Idee auch schon länger besprochen.
Irgendwie zu sagen, so gib uns, wenn wir das wirklich brauchen, deine deine Website irgendwie als.
Kampagnenzipfel daran machen.
Kampagnenzipfel, kann man ja alles schön machen. Die äh,
Sache ist, man muss wahrscheinlich wirklich solche Leute wie die IFF und äh solche Gruppen da an Bord haben, damit wirklich die Leute äh hinrennen und sage ich mal,
ernsthaft jemandem die Möglichkeit in die Hand drücken, diese Seite abzuschalten, ja. Ähm.
Na gut, also Internetdefen klingt so ein bisschen nach Superhelden, ja?
Denke auch, also das ist ja, sie werden, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen mehr machen, ja? Also äh.
Gibt's ja auch bald so einen Film. Ja, wo dann so ein Marktzuckerberg mit mit aber der ist nicht dabei, ne, Facebook?
Nee, der auf Facebook. Gibt's die noch?
Ich glaube schon.
Man munkelt, die die Aktie hat ja äh.
Gut Geld verdient haben, die trotzdem.
Die haben Geld verdient, ja klar. Wie das so ist, ne. Die Anleger jetzt erstmal nicht.
Verschwindet man ja nicht gleich äh aus dem Netz, ne?
Na ja, also Facebook steckt hier nicht äh äh dahinter, aber so eine neue Garde von äh Superhelden macht sich hier auf. Internet zu beschützen. Ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht schlecht reden. Ist natürlich immer gut, wenn ähm Leute sich da zusammentun.
Und äh ja, ist interessant, ne, dass hier so die Blogger freitauschgemeinde sie
da mit der äh schon immer auf Freiheit orientierten Aktivisten Szene äh verbindet. Das liest sich jetzt noch nicht wie ein ähm überrollende Teilnahme so, also es ist jetzt sind zwar schon ein paar Namen, aber halt auch nur ein paar.
Ja, die werden schon ihre große Reihe an Leuten haben, die da jetzt irgendwie äh noch mitmachen, ne? Und das ist ja also das,
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall gut, dass sie, ich meine, die haben siebentausenddrei, nee, siebentausenddreihundert Facebook Likes. Ja,
ähm und,
Also ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz gute Idee und ist auch gar nicht verkehrt, dass so Bot Netz mäßig äh in Anführungszeichen einfach mal auszurollen. Äh weil man da natürlich noch viel mehr Seiten mit dunkel kriegt. Ähm,
Also für, wie gesagt, finde ich eine finde ich eine gute Idee. Wurde bei uns auch schon diskutiert. Vielleicht äh wird
da noch ein deutsches Pendant zu kommen oder man schließt sich irgendwie mit den, von Deutschland aus mit denen zusammen und macht, okay, sagt, okay, wir machen dann deutsche Version von oder wie auch immer. Und was ihr auf jeden Fall jetzt als nächstes ins Auge gefasst haben, ist der,
CISPA,
wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, so hieß er, den hatten wir auch bereits behandelt.
Und natürlich ActA und damit werden wir dann, denke ich, auch beim nächsten Thema.
Kannst du mal auf den Beamer wieder die Themenliste.
Ja, ja, ich bin schon dabei, der Herr.
Genau. Ah ja, die Abstimmung äh im EU-Parlament, es ist nämlich jetzt bald soweit, es wird jetzt über Akte entschieden und ich glaube, es wird auch in diesem Falle äh entschieden oder morgen. Ähm.
Und zwar äh geht das jetzt gerade in diese ganzen Ausschüsse hinein. Ich suche jetzt mal ganz kurz welche das sind.
Ähm also es es rollt jetzt quasi dieser dieser Moment an, dass das EU-Parlament über Acta äh entscheidet und wir erinnern uns ja, dass äh.
Neli Krus uns ja schon gesagt hatte.
Sollten uns keine Sorgen.
Keine Sorgen machen.
Auch immer das bedeutet.
Der Industrieausschuss, der Itre, dann der äh äh Bürgerrechtsausschuss, der Liebe und der Rechtsausschuss der Juri, die ähm,
setzen sich wenn ich das jetzt hier richtig sehe, am Morgen mit diesen Fragen auseinander am Donnerstag, den einunddreißigsten, werden die sich da schon mal ein bisschen äh,
auseinandersetzen. Und da gibt's dann eben natürlich auch wieder die Kampagnenseite von digitaler Gesellschaft verlinkt, wo dann die Ausschussmitglieder gelistet sind, dass man ihnen noch eine E-Mail schreiben kann. Das sollte man dann möglichst wahrscheinlich heute tun. Ansonsten ist ja dann für den,
neunten Juni der weltweite, na ja, weiß nicht, ob er weltweit ist, aber der der große Akte-Aktionstag angekündigt, da habe ich auch nochmal die die äh Einzelstädte, wo da die ganzen Demos stattfinden verlinkt.
Ja, also muss man jetzt so ein bisschen schauen, ne. Wie gesagt, das.
Thema ist dann beerdigt, wenn es, wenn es wirklich beerdigt ist und ich man ich habe mein persönlicher Eindruck ist so ein bisschen auch an mir selber, dass mich natürlich diese aktuellen Zwischen nervt, man möchte ja immer wieder was anderes haben, aber ähm.
Es es ist offensichtlich und oder relativ.
Genau. Wir müssen das jetzt final bekämpfen, damit wir uns auch was Neues einschießen.
Genau, es gibt erst was Neues, wenn ihr so das demonstriert ihr jetzt noch zu Ende und da könnt ihr euch was Neues suchen, ja. So machen wir das.
So machen wir das. Okay, na dann sind wir hier durch mit unserer äh sechsundzwanzigsten Folge, oder?
Ich denke ja. Ich denke, ich denke ja, ich bin ich bin sehr gerührt.
Ja. Auch wenn wir schon, ja, die Fähigkeit, ganze Sätze zusammenzubauen, äh verloren haben. Ich schließe damit dann, wie angekündigt, mit Ernst Jandel.
Manche meinen lechts und rings kann man nicht verwechseln. Verch ein Irrtum.